y en directo Ah Vamos hasta Buenos Aires
Argentina para hablar con nuestro
corresponsal natalio costoy sobre las
amenazas de bombas reportadas en la casa
rosada sede del poder ejecutivo y que
provocó la evacuación del edificio y
también en el Ministerio de defensa
donde estaba prevista la llegada del
presidente Alberto Fernández natalio muy
buenas noches cuéntenos Qué es lo último
que se sabe al respecto
bueno así es la información que primero
se conoció por medios locales es que
hubo unos llamados prácticamente
simultáneos al número de emergencias de
Argentina que es el 911
alertando sobre esta o avisando una
amenaza de de bomba o de explosivos en
la casa rosada en la casa de gobierno y
en el edificio del Ministerio de defensa
el Ministerio de defensa iba a
participar y participó de hecho el
presidente Alberto Fernández de un
evento una cena de cámara de herida
militar
allí la realidad es que yo me comuniqué
para para confirmar con la policía
federal y me dijeron que que se había
hecho el barrido que habían ido a
chequear el lugar y que tras el chequeo
dieron cuenta de que no había explosivo
vídeo negativo a la búsqueda de
explosivos en el lugar de hecho este
este mismo día viernes más temprano por
la mañana mediodía hubo también una
amenaza de bomba en la ex escuela de
mecánica de la armada que era un centro
clandestino de detención durante la
dictadura y se convirtió en democracia
en años recientes en un espacio donde
funcionan muchos este centros y
organismos de Derechos Humanos también
hubo que hacer un desalojo también en la
policía verificó y no encontró ninguna
explosivo no en términos de hipótesis de
que puede haber detrás de esto la verdad
que no hay hipótesis claras que me hayan
podido compartir es muy prematuro no es
la primera vez que ocurre este tipo de
llamados de amenazas en Argentina la
realidad es que no no suelen estar
acompañadas por hechos concretos de
atentados Pero bueno obviamente llaman a
una reacción por parte de los servicios
de seguridad Charles sobre todo después
del intento de asesinato contra la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández de
kirchners a propósito de este tema Cuál
es la situación de seguridad ahí en ese
país
luego del atentado del intento atentado
contra la vicepresidenta un refuerzo de
su custodia de la suya y la de su hijo
máximo kirchner que es diputado nacional
también del frente de todos del partido
de gobierno también una preocupación
sobre sobre su seguridad se aumentó la
custodia y además se está revisando y se
está viendo Y por qué hubo
cuestionamientos al accionar de la
custodia durante ese evento que pudo
haber terminado si no hubiera ocurrido
de otro modo en la muerte de la
vicepresidenta Así que hay un refuerzo
en ese sentido Pero más allá del
refuerzo específico y de ciertos
cuidados que puede haber no es que ha
cambiado la seguridad general de la
nación si en el caso específico por
supuesto de la vicepresidenta Y
seguramente hay un ojo puesto más fuerte
de las fuerzas de seguridad y de las
custodias sobre personajes importantes
funcionarios importantes del gobierno